what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here today to cover
the Ahsoka trailer uh yeah got up at
like 6 30 in the morning to make sure my
Creed video went live and now it has
been rendered obsolete because
apparently there was a bunch of Star
Wars announcements my wife was like Hey
thisoka trailers out well what I was
like yup yup it's in my notifications I
called Michael and John Michael picked
up Michael is here our Star Wars nerd
expert so happy you're here I'm so happy
to be here and I told him on the phone
like don't look up any of the
celebration announcements because I
might want to talk about it and uh so I
know like the title for the celebrate I
don't know the details but yeah I know
nothing it's really hard being a reject
right now because I need to know right
now so you do it that's why we reject
anyway people use the force to leave a
like that would mean a lot let's see
what's going on in this trailer let's go
[Music]
something's coming
something dark
oh my God
is it
this is something there she is hey wow
for some
War
got our first Sabine look huh Chopper
whoa who's that
you know that I don't know that looks
like a stiff acolyte of some kind oh wow
with all it's been a while
things have changed
I started hearing whispers
that's a great um is that a cover or
something
it's heir to the Empire
through the empire
[Music]
to prepare for the worst wow
wow this is straight up a Rebels a long
time ago
oh it's like bro wow there aren't many
left
[Music]
was that
uh Ezra
oh interesting question
it is time to begin again
[Music]
wait a minute I think I know that
what was that droid's name uh that's the
the Droid who built all the lightsabers
it has a
oh my God I I feel like I know the name
it's on the tip of my tongue uh it's
gonna come to me it sounds like it
sounds like Harang from Tekken but it's
yes that's exactly what it is
but no is that uh let's rewind it was
that Ezra in the Hologram okay really
quick this thrawn look isn't that the
that's like a famous cover or something
yeah I mean that's that's the cover of
uh
several yeah books I've never read it
I've seen a lot of them
books that's Ezra right
I think so yeah this looks like the guy
who they cast but it's so small yeah
it's hard to they have the uh and they
have Sabine looking at him so I was I
would assume that's Ezra anyway you know
what I think that's a flashback hologram
of Ezra Bridger oh
because she's she's looking I think
she's on the fall uh in the little
Hideout probably longing for her old
friend okay so let's go through this a
little bit first off I thought the
trailer was excellent yeah uh like just
tonally cinematic wise if it does feel
like this is just a sequel to Rebels
which I'm here for which is kind of
surprising to me because I feel like if
you haven't seen Rebels you'll be very
much left out love how Zeb is in
Mandalore he's nowhere I I think I feel
very confident we're gonna see Zeb yeah
more than likely because if Hera is out
here that means zeb's coming along for
the ride okay so here what is this is
this a Jedi Temple uh that would appear
well so interesting a lot of the symbols
that we're seeing in the background
um if we remember kind of the the time
Travel how Ahsoka was saved in Rebels
the wall behind walls
yes names and titles are not my special
tickets that vague memories
early in the morning we'll give you a
write-off part of where thrawn uh and
Ezra ended up with the pergil is kind of
in this unknown region uh beyond
reachable space okay and that's the
quest of where we're going There's
Something Brewing there
um you know the yuzan vong uh or the
grisk as they've been kind of renamed uh
in the comics is kind of why thrawn got
involved in the empire in the first
place because there's this species that
represents like an existential crisis to
the Galaxy and the emperor was even
worried and it was like building up to
prepare for it and with the absence of
the Empire thrawn and and his species
are kind of on their own uh and I think
that's what Ahsoka is alluding to and
I'm so excited to have like a new
foreign big bad in Star Wars I love the
heir to the Empire line oh yeah what a
wonderful reference I think Sabine looks
dope uh like one of my favorite I love
cat I'm just uh I love lethal the lost
cat they've seen lost cats before
haven't we yeah this is so real this is
like this is like a puppet yeah the
other ones are like hyper CGI I wonder
if this will be a reoccurring love cat
oh man
um yeah because if I think if you look
right there to the right you can see the
beginnings of the the famous mural of
the rebels crew and then for for reasons
unknown uh probably the costume just
didn't quite work but uh the Gandalf the
White of Ahsoka I think got cut based on
the sure which is sad I was super here
for it
um what are the these like Sith like
villains they're not they're not they
can't be inquisitors well it's post
inquisitors
um but I mean listen there's there's a
lot of Sith acolytes out there in in the
galaxy
my hair looks amazing yeah and they've
mastered the Twilight look yeah oh I it
took him about it I'm kind of curious
how they time it all out because she's a
general uh for the new Republic and like
if you've played like squadrons uh she's
a really big part of that and like the
new Republic error so I'm curious as to
what extent she's gonna play I wonder if
maybe she helps them commandeer a vessel
or or figure out a way and I would love
to see her all the way through the other
thing that we're not seeing here is
there should be a little kit next to her
in the form of her kid uh with Kanan
jarus okay I don't know who these new
people are yeah but looks like Chloe
Grace Moretz but it's not she doesn't
seem like she's doing well mentally so
that's a good sign uh but the Sith here
do look yeah look at the lethal looks so
good uh
I do love seeing this brought to life
yeah so so this is cool I mean this is
the new republic government a mon mothma
Chancellor uh at this point in time she
looked great for her age
she is not aged today uh we get so much
Mothman one thing that Disney era really
runs this is significant about him it's
a strange character to give that much
but I'm so here for it one of my
favorites
um she was in Mando season two had a
dope duel with soap that's when we asked
where is thrawn who is oh this is the is
this the no it's not oh is it the it
could be is that space what the hell is
it called the wall behind the Spaceballs
Bales what the hell is that called Greg
I'm gonna let you struggle on this
because it's really fun to watch they
might be although I get the sense this
might also maybe be a temple or or a set
this looks like a set
oh that's that's kind of interesting uh
I mean look almost looks like an
excavation site uh oh yeah yeah I mean
it stands to reason that there are oh
wow she looks so good uh it stands there
isn't that you know outside of the known
Galaxy there are Sith like
acolytes and you know
um or maybe something completely
different
um this one looks so intimidating yeah I
love the shot that it seems like it's
hearkening to that Rogue one but yeah
he's great yeah this looks so good was
the double lightsaber the same one of
the same two people we've seen it is an
Inquisitor lightsaber
uh uh do you see the circle
yeah I could see it totally a thousand
percent okay in this really fast moving
motion well I don't know Greg you have
better eyes than I do I'm not seeing the
circle well I see the circle now that's
hard Circle because you want to see this
um what is the text say I didn't even
like process
Rebel which is great because Jedi
Outcast is one of the best Star Wars
games ever made but is she a Jedi well
no she's
something more
and something less I love how we got
like that goofy ass episode of episode
six of the Mandalorian then we get this
like beautifully yeah this is really
hard to to like and you know why your
white her lightsabers are white right uh
now she bled out the red of the crystals
of the inquisitors that she killed oh
okay is that not really sick uh and this
is great because that indicates we're
building lightsabers and I'm so glad he
survived he's like the the Treasure
Trove of knowledge for the Jedi Order
and you remember his name Greg it is not
a wrong
it might be
uh okay I'm embarrassed uh but it's
really early in the morning so I'm gonna
type in harong Rebels I think it's like
you you no
yo you're on to it uh are you young h y
yeah wait wait who Young
you got it yeah
you can see how I got her wrong bro yeah
no it's super Fair a little offensive
but super Fair
anyway uh yeah I thought that was a
beautiful trailer all right Ahsoka guys
what did you think about this trailer
leave your thoughts down below thank you
Michael for showing up and being the
professor for us I really appreciate it
of course guys I gotta get this video to
you we're running who's came out like
hours ago bye
[Music]